[Music]
obvious outie product placement within
the first three minutes man I hope that
motorcycles owner isn't standing right
next to it oh good he's nothing this is
the exact same setting from taken to
that's not exactly something to be proud
of
look the motorcycle can bounce backwards
off the rail or it can flip up over the
rail but it definitely can't do both
you guys know what's at stake here we
cannot afford to lose that I am the
worst micromanager in history I'm pretty
sure this girl's only in this movie to
say the names of the sponsoring
companies doesn't anyone operating the
Train know that is going down so they
could stop it all train tracks have
roads running alongside them for just
this type of situation why is there a
random broken piece of chain just
sitting atop this rapidly moving train
car this gun shop this fall and this
drowning would definitely have killed
Bob Adele gee I wonder for whom that
Bell Tolls what your hairline
never picks up her handbag but it's gone
if she's leaving the room some people
think we should do more of this that's
traumatic and all but are we supposed to
believe England's top spy base is
susceptible to a computer hack that can
cause explosions wait bond is still
alive so he was really saved by those
mermaids that wasn't just a dream the
opening credits sequence and now we have
Heineken this movie was paid for in full
by the 22 minute mark this remote barn
paradise has their TV set to CNN she's
the head of mi6 and someone just blew up
her office yet there's no extra security
at her house or any security at all does
this guy say something to bond stop wait
for bond to start doing a different
exercise and then continue talking like
nothing ever happened
yeah don't kill the bad guy while he's
occupied moving bodies or anything no
definitely wait until you have to
perform this dangerous stunt to catch up
to it no wait I was wrong you should
wait until this guy builds his gun then
cuts the glass then shoots this other
before you do anything
definitely trust any screen that has
obviously been hacked and clicked the
click here to claim your prize' button
couldn't mi6 just this you or take down
notice to get YouTube to pull these
videos it's almost like this movie is
daring us to make this video that dress
is not backless dude its sheer with
little frilly things oh my god job came
back it's hard to find this scene sexy
when I'm unable to forget the preceding
conversation where bond discovered this
girl was sold into the sex
at the age of 12 seen does not contain a
lapdance I don't really want to out
myself as a secret agent but that's not
how hydrogen cyanide works too bad
there's not a way to analyze Silva's
computer without hooking it directly
into the mi6 Network oh there's a crack
door definitely means the bad guy went
this way how is this train completely
empty during rush hours let's talk about
Silva's plan this movie is telling us
that Silva New Bond would find this
casino trip in Shanghai Bond would then
go to Macau find this prostitute get led
to this remote island also Silva could
get caught and then he knew the queue
would hook up the computer at the right
moment solved the encryption releasing
him from the glass cage he knew he would
be in and also somehow knew that when he
flew up mi6 they would move to this
underground location that hasn't been
used in decades he's able to overpower
all the supposedly trained armed guards
after he breaks out knows bond will
follow him down into the subway even
smirks when he thinks he's lost bond but
still has this explosive rig so that the
ridiculous train will fall down into it
for some reason just happens to have
guys waiting at the courthouse and in a
plan that apparently took years to map
out manages to know for a fact that M
will be at a hearing on this very day at
this very time and he'll be able to get
there in time to shoot up the courthouse
after the Joker in low key this is the
third stupidest get yourself captured
and then escape with no real other
objective plan I've ever heard in my
life
what Silva planned for everything else
but not the fire extinguisher truth
pretty silly thing to leave a chance
Silva I wish there was a way to know
what kind of laptop Q is using somewhere
we'll have exactly how is it an
advantage to go out the bonds old house
in Scotland in the middle of nowhere
with very few weapons and no
reinforcements Idaho it's not a real
place well now that I've fired two
gunshots I guess I'm a professional
again killers who think they're sneaking
up on bond entered through the front
gate shouldn't Silva maybe have
coordinated the helicopters arrival with
the actual attack on the ground by his
henchmen are they seriously using a
flashlight are these people amateurs
Emma's the head of a spy agency and it's
amazing how much light there is down
here in this water you were on a mission
with her when this movie opened like
partners you didn't know her name but
you knew Roth's on the dying agents name
come on
you